the 2015 Mustang is important not only
because it's Ford's only sports car but
because it is the iconic American muscle
car that focused our Fascination on all
things on four wheels for 50 years here
we go
ready this is absolutely
insane but this isn't your grandfather's
Mustang it also isn't your
dad's the 2015 Mustang is a radical
departure from last year's model with
multiple drive by wire driving modes
launch control and independent rear
suspension each wheel is independently
suspended as opposed to a live rear axle
that you previously had that means it
can stick to the tarmac much better and
you don't lose the rear end as much as
you did in previous
Mustangs the pony now has a lot of
competition and the class has gotten
bigger and bigger Mustang is on track to
be outs sold by the Camaro for the fifth
straight year in a row but now for the
first time in 50 years Ford wants to
sell the Mustang overseas we're going to
sell to over 120 countries and we're
going rightand drive as well as leftand
so and and we're offering Fastback
convertible but in the end the car is
truly a Mustang and the question is is
can this car with the incredible
American Spirit actually compete with
its modern European Rivals that's what
we've come here to find
out Ford says they did Benchmark this
car against a 911 not only a base
Carrera but a Carrera S So the faster
version of the
911 the quality is a little bit too good
if you're used to driving the last
Mustang GT it felt like there was just a
ton of brutes force uh at your beck and
call whenever you wanted it now this car
doesn't feel like that and I think the
problem is because it's so much
smoother it's still tons of fun and
it'll still make you smile I mean you
know what I mean I know what you're
talking about you just got the car super
capable so you just got to find the even
better roads that put put that pucker
Factor on you at the end of the day it
could come down to
price